our next
speaker
uh you may have seen her from such
conferences as the new york r conference
a few months ago
and very importantly
she is a
jeep wrangler owner
and a goodwill and thrift store power
shopper
everyone please welcome asama
it's really my my pleasure and my honor
to to talk about
what we do at pursue care
we are a startup company which
specializes in treating substance use
disorder
and specifically today i'm going to talk
about how we use data and r to improve
that care
okay
um so i wanted to start with just
impressing upon you all the enormous
human toll
that opioid overdoses have on this
country
every day
136 people
die from what is essentially something
that could be
preventable
and
so in understanding um this this
epidemic or really this this crisis uh
what we mean by it
is the
substantial medical social
psychological and economic consequences
due to the misuse and the overdose
deaths of a class of drugs called
opioids
from 1999 to 2019 nearly 500 000 people
have died from an overdose involving any
opioid which includes
both prescription and illicit opioids
and that number
of drug overdose deaths has quadrupled
since 1999.
the reason why we focus or so many of
our efforts are focused on opioids
specifically is because over 70 percent
of the deaths in 2019 have occurred
because of prescription or illicit
opioids
um so since 2019 and and since the
pandemic started
from the cdc's 12-month ending
provisional numbers
we've seen
a sharp increase in the number of deaths
unfortunately predictably so
opioid use and and misuse
can be thought of as a disease of
despair
and i think all the challenges
many of us have encountered during this
pandemic or even more amplified for the
marginalized populations who suffer
from opioid use and misuse
we've seen racial disparities get
magnified
um across all
economic stratas
and so we've seen the number
of overdose deaths
deaths jump from 56 000
to 75 000 in just um a 12-month period
so many efforts have been deployed to
curb this this crisis
um
payers
government agencies
private companies such as ourselves
and what we do
to do our part is we want to be able to
give patients
the ability to access care in a
convenient way and that fits around
their life
and so many of our own efforts are
deployed to reach at-risk populations
and give them the care that they need
from their own homes
and so through a combination of
telehealth and in-person clinics
we deliver a continuum of services from
screening and assessment to medication
treatment to
case management
and
cognitive behavioral therapies
so that includes medication assisted
treatment
individual group therapy
psychiatric care
digital therapeutics
and medications from our own pharmacy
and so my role in in all of this
uh was to build you know a data science
driven company given that we are a
digital first company so everything is
is truly data
so my personal goals when i when i
joined the company was to understand uh
the business
and the the scope of of
the the crisis that we're experiencing
in fact for my first three weeks i i
didn't write a single line of code
next
i needed to determine and anticipate the
needs of the key stakeholders in the
company so that involved a lot of
sit-down meetings with different
departments and understanding how they
currently utilize data if they do so and
then anticipate what kind of
data needs they would need to help them
better improve their own internal
processes and help them become more
efficient
and thirdly i needed to
[Music]
just assess ways in which i can use data
to help us deliver on our mission and
core values which is to improve patient
intake
care and retention given that retention
is is really the biggest predictor of a
long-term successful recovery
and so i was trying to find
a gift that
kind of summarizes the experience of
being
a company's first data scientist i think
it starts with really elation
at joining a company with you know no
legacy code no legacy tech stack you can
kind of get to choose and pick uh what
what tools make you the happiest
uh but then i think it it it can be
stressful given that you know you are
wearing multiple hats
um you know data scientist you're also
kind of a data engineer and a research
scientist and a project manager and a
software engineer and it and devops nml
ops um so it can get to be a lot but
it's incredibly incredibly exciting and
i think
the elation continued for me because we
truly have incredible tools at our
disposal and i'm gonna talk about those
for a little bit
and so before we really talk about the
tools right i think it's it's you run
into trouble when you look at tools and
you're like okay how can i use the tools
as opposed to having an approach first
of like
what do i need to accomplish and then
thinking about the tools that help you
accomplish those goals so
some of the key considerations
uh when i first started is okay where
where is the data how is it stored
um can we maybe think about better ways
in which it can be stored more
efficiently
and
is the data even ready so do we need to
process it or anything like that
what tech stock is is needed
for that data
and what tools are best for efficiency
automation
reproducibility and reporting
and finally what is the personnel needed
to to make all this happen
so
starting with personnel actually
that might be the very first
consideration
in in all of this um and i
remember tweeting out not not long ago
um
jokingly
like what do data scientists want and
and turns out they only want one thing
and it's disgusting and it's data
engineers and
found that out pretty pretty early on
that i really could not do everything i
couldn't be both a data scientist and a
data engineer and a research scientist
and all of those and so investing in
that in that personnel was was really
key in getting us up and running
so i think really minimally
this is the team that that we first
started with with me a data engineer and
i t support
and the next thing that i think was
important
for us
was to use internal packages we have
such such a small team really as me
being the only and principal data
scientist
and so
i
remember reading emily ryder's blog post
about internal packages and it really
just opened my eyes to
how useful they could be and i and i'm
just gonna take a quote from her
so internal tools have
great potential to improve an
organization's code quality promote
reproducible analysis frameworks and
enhance
knowledge management
and this graph she used
was
was perfect uh because you know i
thought i could pretty much do it all
and and relatively fast and relatively
well with the open source packages that
our our studio
have
um but as we can see from this graph you
know they
they do address a lot of of problems and
and goals that that you want
but
their solution breath may not be as high
as internal packages because you can
sort of configure these packages to be
the most efficient for the use cases
that you have
and so given once again how small
our our team was
for the sake of efficiency
and automation
investing in making our own internal
packages was key
so some of those packages involve
a
data package so one that pulls data from
different sources that we use on a
regular basis
such as
data from the cdc data from the new york
times for covin 19 data
data from
government agencies and cities
next we wanted a package to
help us just with database connections
and querying api requests and etl
processes
and then a package
for the data manipulations and the data
visualizations that we were doing
over and over and over again
so zooming into the data manipulation
and visualizations
including for our internal packages
we make very heavy use of the tidy verse
i'm not gonna go through each package or
anything but just to highlight the ones
that have made just a tremendous
difference
in our efficiency
deep flyer of course for
general wrangling ggplot2 for
visualizations stringar for
text stuff per
tidyr fur
for
you know functional programming
lubridae to wrangle dates skimar to
continuously preview and assess the data
janitor for cleaning and quick frequency
tables
and many others that that we utilize
also on a regular basis um such as tidy
text for text mining
and some packages from from the open
source community like layla's package
called dope for drug parsing
for modeling
we
actually only make use of of tidy models
really because it's just a tremendous
ecosystem of packages that help you with
the modeling process really from
start to
finish
and we use
the tidy models ecosystem to perform
statistical inference
survival analysis
and prediction
and so
these allow us to detect
and assess trends
at the population level at the provider
level
at the individual patient level
it they allow us to evaluate practices
internally
which then help us inform
what those practices ought to be
so this this is hugely helpful in
personalizing care for our patients
and then of course the continuous
monitoring of outcomes
and
assessing who may be most at risk for
treatment lapses and and so on
and so one thing that jared has has
talked about um
is
you know this this common pitfall that
that many of us may encounter um in
which you know you open a project you
run the code and depending on
how computationally heavy that that
could be you know
minutes or hours
you wait uh for that code to run and
then you
you run into some errors and then you
have to go and fix them and then have to
restart this uh
from scratch
and so
we don't have to live this way
people have um created packages um for
us to do that and the targets package is
is extremely powerful in that in that
sense so it is a pipeline toolkit for
reproducibility
the amazing thing about it is although
there are many tools this one is
specifically designed for r so you can
stay in r the entire time
it saves on computation with parallel
computing skips steps that are already
up to date and don't need to be run
and then that diagram that jared shows
um
you know gives you confidence that that
what you're doing is is truly
reproducible and so given that you know
we are a shop that uses data science
we're also very invested in research and
so this is a huge
win in in that regard
and so one of the most important things
of course uh for us is is reporting
right um so the key considerations here
is that um i did want to stay all in r
or our studio
i wanted that reporting to be
customizable in which i could throw up
you know my company's logo
wanted it to be lightweight and and
portable so easily shareable and i
wanted of course version control
and so
uh there are
amazing packages to help and do that so
starting with blastula which allows
for you to send emails from r so so
that's really helpful for daily kpi
distribution key performance indicators
our markdown
and flex dashboard together to make
reports html reports or to make those
into
dashboards
and sharing in for presentations and so
these four
we use
every day for
kpi distributions
monthly quarterly yearly reports
dashboards and presentations that we can
make iteratively without having to
recode them every single time
and so that's all great you know making
making this but how do we actually
deliver it to
key stakeholders
and
the tool we use is our studio connect
which for the consideration we just
spoke about about wanting to stay all in
r in our studio
that goes obviously a huge way
and so our studio connect is is that
publishing platform for those dashboards
and those on-demand and scheduled
reports and those presentations and even
apis and and and many more
so the advantage is there once again is
that you you never have to leave r r
studio it also can publish python code
for you i've never made use of python
but maybe one day
and then the third and
possibly one of the biggest
considerations is security given that we
are dealing with
confidential
patient data and so you can
uh very easily control who sees what on
that on that platform
and so i just wanted to to end here with
you know sort of the motivation for why
we do this work and why we get up every
day
is is for patients like this who
continue to inspire and astonish all of
us
this patient says i just wanted to thank
you and everyone else that has gotten
me this far i didn't think it was going
to happen without me driving to
pennsylvania but thanks to you guys i
finally have a doctor appointment and i
really appreciate you all so that's what
we're all about we're about lowering
that
barrier
to
treatment access
and uh we're
we're very happy to have the tools that
allow us to do that every day so huge
shout out to the open source community
and our studio
and everyone that i got to know through
twitter couldn't couldn't make this
happen without you guys so
thank you and
if you do want to reach out
by email or twitter please feel free to
do so and i hope
that if you want to get involved there's
many opportunities to do so
both
code wise but but also community wise i
encourage everyone to
look into narcan training
which
is oftentimes free
and offered multiple times a year in
which
they teach you how to recognize the
signs of an overdose and then administer
a life-saving drug called narcan which
reverses overdoses so with that thanks
once again and looking forward to
connect with you all